[Risas]
[Música]
y hablar de cómo cambiar la cadena de
sus bicicletas o reparar un neumático
desinflado lo hice mil veces en la ruta
pero mi objetivo es otro los y las
quiero invitar a recordar nuestra
infancia por unos segundos recuerdan esa
emoción que sintieron al mantener por
primera vez el equilibrio en una
bicicleta después de haber tenido por
tanto tiempo el apoyo de las rueditas
traseras lo recuerdan yo lo recuerdo
perfectamente la primera sensación de
equilibrio en mi bicicleta la velocidad
del viento en mi cara los árboles en
movimiento mis piernas mis brazos mis
manos manteniendo ese control fue una
sensación de libertad maravillosa pero
el ser humano tiene esa misma sensación
cuando comienza a caminar la diferencia
es que no es consciente
nadie la recuerda
pero en cambio en la bici si a mí me
marcó mucho ese momento porque sin
saberlo
esa sensación me acompaña hasta el día
de hoy pero hoy no son las ruedas
pequeñas las que me ayudan a ese
equilibrio sino las dos grandes ruedas
de un carro de arrastre que lleva dentro
sueños deseos imaginación historias
aventuras y sonrisas a distintas
comunidades de américa como en la
revolucionaria selva de lacandona o en
la posible y tranquila ribera maya en la
sentida y dolorosa jobs y napa donde 43
almas desaparecieron de manera forzadas
de sus aulas en la mágica oaxaca tierra
de maría sabina sintiéndome envuelto por
sus densas nubes en el desierto de san
luís de potosí
viendo como el tren de la muerte se
llevaba niños y anillas
al gabacho para cumplir el falso sueño
americano en la frontera guatemalteca
coimeando al personal aduanero con
libros para poder pasar pedalear
regresar pedalear pasar y regresar
pedalear pasar y regresar a méxico
también en la terremoteada ruta de la
costa afro ecuatoriana o por la extensa
amazonía brasilera colombiana peruana
ecuatoriana navegando sobre sus
contaminadas aguas de color negro sobre
el barro que pavimentan las carreteras
para cruzar al río beni o en el
altiplano de la cordillera de los andes
pedaleando bajo la mirada de los
cóndores isla dawson ex centro de
tortura y también isla navarino donde
cinco sonrisas nos esperaban con un
calor intenso a tres grados bajo cero
en el extremo sur del mundo estas son
las rutas de un biblio cretario un
biblio cretario de una biblioteca si
escucharon bien de una biblioteca es
decir una biblioteca que no es estática
ni silenciosa que no tiene paredes y no
tiene horarios tiene dos ruedas adelante
y dos ruedas atrás cuatro alforjas que
transportan un retablo de títeres y de
objetos que dan forma a una oficina de
un oficio tan antiguo como ser un
titiritero en ella se fomenta la lectura
se crean mundos se donan libros se arman
rincones literarios se alfabetiza se lee
se escucha pero lo más importante se
juega este proyecto tiene sus inicios en
mexico
estuvieron presente dos compañeras de
ruta una de argentina y la otra de chile
quienes fueron fundamentales para su
desarrollo sin ellas no hubiera sido
posible ya saben ese proverbio que dice
si quieres ir rápido viaja solo y si
quieres llegar lejos viaja acompañado
fue entonces que decidí ser un biblio
cretario concentrar mi energía en darle
vida al proyecto biblio que estás por el
mundo que poderoso es un libro en la
mano de un ser humano da esperanza abre
rutas alimenta la imaginación responde y
crean y más pero no es solamente llevar
libros viajar en bicicleta o ser un
titiritero 4x4 es saber que vas a dar
con los libros que el mundo vas a
descubrir
el libro vas a donar si van a aguantar
las rutas por el continente sus lluvias
sus vientos el sol si son muy antiguos
si sirven o no la calidad de sus hojas
el tamaño de sus letras sus lenguajes
sus imágenes si son para pintar o no y
si son para pintar hay que llevar
lápices de colores y de cera entonces el
carro de arrastre aparte de tener su
propia compañía de títeres empieza a
hacer una escuela itinerante llevando
pegamentos reglas tijeras y un
kamishibai para contar historias por eso
decidí incentivar la lectura a través
del teatro de objeto y llegar a los
niños y niñas de cada escuela rural de
cada comunidad de cada pueblo afectado
por una catástrofe natural crisis social
o humanitaria lo que me hace vibrar y
sentirme orgulloso al decir que soy un
biblio cretario no son las rutas
no sólo es kilómetros recorridos sino
que son esos corazones llenos de
curiosidad interés atracción cuando me
ven llegando y diciendo que trae ahí ya
saben si quieres llegar lejos viaja
acompañado hoy me acompaña un gran
elenco de títeres un banda un jaguar una
tortuga marina un oso perezoso un burro
un pato un león un tigre dos gallinas un
gallo un extraterrestre y un monstruo de
las profundidades de la tierra todos
embajadores de la imaginación y eso es
lo mágico de este proyecto como todo en
la vida
hay sacrificios con los que uno tiene
que lidiar para funcionar como biblio
cretario no tienes las comodidades
cotidianas de vivir en una ciudad ya no
tienes el refrigerador lleno de
alimentos como cuando vivías con tu
familia ni el espacio suficiente para
tus cosas ni un baño pero cuando pedaleo
por la ruta con mi carro de arrastre con
todo lo que llevo en él no existe el
sacrificio sino sólo el placer hoy de
regreso en mi país chile siento que todo
este esfuerzo puede abrir camino a
muchos bibliotecarios y bibliotecarias
para que integren esta red de incentivo
a la lectura porque el objetivo es justo
y la necesidad urgente desafío a los ya
las artistas y docentes de américa a que
me ayuden a sembrar bibliotecas por el
mundo
[Aplausos]